book notes is author robert carroll he
continues his narrative on the life of
lyndon johnson in means of ascent the
second volume in the series
he chronicles johnson's struggles after
his defeat in the 1941 campaign for the
senate through his final years in texas
and his election to the senate in 1948
robert carroll shares his insights into
our 30th president and his stories
gathered in over 14 years of research
[Music]
robert carro author of the years of
lyndon johnson
means of ascent and the back of your
book
you admit that you looked at 629 000
pages of documents
or at least they were put in front of
you how in the world did you read all
that
well i spent a lot of years on this um
and a lot of those years a lot of months
in those years
so you just sit there you know when i
was a newspaper reporter just starting
out i was at 20 and i had this editor
who told me turn every page never assume
anything and with his early life at
least it was physically possible to look
at every piece of paper how much
new information is it i know it's a
tough question to answer but a lot of
new information in these books this is
your second book well i think it's uh
pretty uh largely new information
because uh
lyndon john you know when i started this
there were already 17 biographies of
lyndon johnson and i felt that his youth
in his early years i would hardly have
to do any work on because i thought they
had been covered over and over again
but when i went to texas
i started finding out
that most of
the stories that we knew about and the
anecdotes so we knew about him were
really a legend that he had
uh in effect created about his life and
it wasn't really
the truth so i had to start all over
again
can you remember the moment the first
moment that you said
i want to do london johnson
well
i was my first i was a reporter on
newsday and what i realized was not that
i wanted to do biographies brian i never
conceived of
writing books just as the lives of
famous men i really had no interest in
that at all what i wanted to do was
explain how political power worked
because i was a reporter
and i was covering politics
and i felt that i wasn't really
explaining what i had gone into the
newspaper business to explain which was
how political power worked and a lot of
it led back to this man robert moses a
lot of what i didn't understand now here
was a guy who was never elected to
anything and i was coming to realize
that he had more power than anyone who
was governor or or mayor who was he by
the way well robert moses
was this park commissioner of new york
and the chairman of the tribal bridge
authority he built every bridge that's
been built in new york since 1930 the
verrazano throgs neck bronx white stone
henry hudson etc he built every mile of
expressway and parkway that's been built
in new york
since the 1920s all the parks he either
built or rebuilt he created
so much of the landscape of new york the
book is called the power broker and i
really picked that title because uh he
wasn't elected to anything he got power
from extra democratic means such as the
public authority he created public
authorities in their present form
but i would be a reporter and no one
knew this including me
and i would be sitting there and you
type city park commissioner robert moses
and i'd wonder what did that have to do
with the fact that he built the long
island expressway where you type tribro
bridge authority chairman robert moses
and he said well what exactly is an
authority you know we thought it was
just something that built one bridge
collected tolls and went out of business
so i really wanted to examine how urban
political power worked i thought i could
do it through the means of the life of
robert moses and all the time i was
doing it
see i never thought i'd get to do
another book because we were just broke
the whole i had a tiny advance no one
thought anyone would be interested in
the book on robert moses what i was
trying to do was finish it what year was
this well it was i it took me seven
years it was published in 74 so i guess
i began in 67
i was just trying to get done so i could
go back to work you know as a reporter
but i knew
that if i ever somehow could
i'd like to do the same thing for
national power as i had done in the
power broker with urban power and i knew
i wanted to do it with lyndon johnson
because i felt he understood national
power better than any other president in
our time
what year was that
well the power broker was published in
74 and i shortly thereafter started on
the lyndon johnson biography what was it
though about lyndon johnson that got
your attention well what kind of regard
my attention was when he was sent see
with moses everyone said no one ever did
this before what he did right he was
never elected to anything but he had
more power now with johnson they said
the same thing no one ever dominated the
senate of the united states like lyndon
johnson
he controlled the senate majority
leaders i said well if no one else did
it if i can find out how he did it and
show how he used
how he obtained this power used it that
was what first got me interested
and what did you do first
first i went to texas
you walk into the lyndon johnson library
the first two floors are a museum then
there's this huge staircase and on top
of it
are four floors there's a glass wall
with four floors of the papers of lyndon
johnson
uh they're all
whatever there are they're 34 million
documents
they're all in these boxes red buckram
boxes stamped with the presidential seal
and gold and they tower up four stories
alright that was the moment i thought of
quitting
actually
and then of course for the next few
years we spent a lot of time my wife
einer and myself in texas
i want to ask you a personal question
i'm not sure you want to answer it um
ask it anyway
how do you afford to do this kind of
thing you spent seven years on robert
moses
and you spent 14 years on london johnson
who pays the bills during these periods
well
it's very different you know for the
first book i did for a tiny advance i
think was a 2500 advance
i nobody was really interested in the
book
and really we were just broke pretty
much for seven years i got a grant for
one year but i thought the book was only
going to take one year you know so at
the end of the year i was just a
reporter we had no savings
we had a house on long island so we sold
that but
that was before the real estate boom
so that gave us enough money after the
mortgage for only 15 more months
we moved into an apartment in riverdale
in new york
and
from time to time i know my wife would
go to work but i also
needed her to help me with the research
on this
and that was a continual struggle i mean
to do the power brokers i look back on
it
well for the first five years or so
then things
change but for the first five years or
so it was just a struggle from months to
months to keep going
then that was not a bestseller at first
but it almost immediately began to be
used by really hundreds of colleges you
know in different courses
and
you know i won the pulitzer prize in
other prizes
and i was able to get a much better
contract
for lyndon johnson and then the first
volume of the johnson of course
was
what their major best seller would have
i know all the money problems have
ceased and it's not even a consideration
is it true that they printed 500 000 of
the first lyndon johnson book well there
are five hundred thousand in print now
yeah more than 500 all hardback
it's in it's in all we we've never had a
mass market paperback i'm not sure if
that figure includes the trade paperback
with the various hardback
editions
i i i that figure that you gave me is
what kanav says and they said it to me
and i i didn't really ask what the
different editions
the first book of about london johnson
was on what subject what part of his
life it was
well it starts really before his life
because i wanted to show what life in
rural texas you know was like and his
ancestors which i thought was such an
important part of his life and it takes
him up to the age of 32
when he
has gets his first national power
and
at the end of that book he tries for the
senate that's the last scene in 1941 and
loses to this texas campaigner path past
the biscuits papio daniel
his hillbilly band that's the end of the
first volume he has national power but
he can't move up to the center
and now the second book focuses on only
seven years of his life
it's after that defeat where he's stuck
in the house of representatives which he
really dislikes
and he cannot find a way to advance
himself politically and his whole life
these are his seven years in the
wilderness it's his seven years he turns
to making money with the radio station
and he's sort of consumed
with his need to try to move up to the
senate
on what he always envisioned as his road
to the presidency
and of course
centerpiece or whatever you want to call
it of this volume
is his last chance in 1948
he decides to take one last chance and
run for the senate he says if he loses
he'll leave politics forever
how many books about lyndon johnson are
you going to write four
what are the next two going to be about
well the next one takes him from being
sworn into the senate
to uh
up through his rise to power in the
senate his majority leadership running
for president against
jack kennedy losing and being the vice
president it ends with the assassination
with him being sworn in on the plane in
dallas and then the last volume uh will
be the presidency i'm determined to try
to do the presidency in one
book because it's one story
read somewhere where you get a a
distillation of all this at the end
you're going to write a fifth book well
i want to do when i'm done yes i want to
distill it down
into a one volume
have you written the third volume
already well i'm writing it right now
yeah this book we're talking about the
one that was just published is to me
almost
you know it's behind me that's the funny
feeling i'm my mind is in the third
volume now johnson is in the center when
did you finish writing this book
oh
i don't know nine months ago ten months
ago so i think i don't really remember
and do you think lyndon johnson all the
time
[Laughter]
is it is it hard to get him out of your
mind
i
well no actually because you see because
you know large parts of the book don't
deal with lyndon johnson like in the
first volume i wanted to talk about him
bringing electricity to the hill country
no one had done that story and i thought
it was important so i just went off to
research electricity and rural
electrification and he's not even in it
you know now in the third volume
the great thing that he does is pass
this first civil rights legislation in a
century in a senate that's dominated by
the south so i'm going back and doing
civil rights history you know so lyndon
lyndon johnson is sort of out of it for
a while that's what keeps it interesting
you know you keep doing
uh going off and doing other things
that are related to this book that's why
i call it the years of lyndon johnson i
wanted to show
american history during the years of his
life and not just his life
when you in your acknowledgments you
thank a lot of people from the lyndon b
johnson
library in austin texas
how many years did you spend in the
library
well
i can't answer that for 14. i've been
working on the book for 14 years
and in each year there there are months
that i spend you know in the library
some less than others i i don't i've
never counted that up we've also spent
you know a lot of time
i living up on the edge of the hill
country in texas so that i could
interview the people in the pertinent
alleys valley where johnson grew up
people who grew up with him the people
went to college with him the people who
were his first political machine
and i wanted to learn that whole culture
of the hill country so i could
understand him better you were born
where i was born in new york city on
central park west where i now live
what's the first thing you noticed that
was different about texas
than more where you grew up texas was so
different you know i had no idea
and i the first
i mean it was one dramatic moment
actually it was dramatic to me i don't
know if it's dramatic to anyone else but
i'd never seen johnson sitting i had no
idea of the loneliness and the emptiness
of the hill country so the first day i
was there i rented a car
and i drove out of austin and towards
johnson city and about 40 to 43 miles
out
you come to the top of what they call
round mountain but it's just really a
high hill but from it you can see this
really vast basin or valley in front of
you
miles long and miles
wide maybe 30 miles long and maybe 15 or
20 miles across
and in this whole area
you couldn't see one sign of human
habitation and then the sun came out
from behind the cloud i had stopped the
car at the top of this thing i was
standing there looking down into it
and the sun came out and suddenly you
saw the sun glinting off the roofs
of this little huddle of houses in the
middle of this emptiness and that was
johnson city and i think i knew in that
moment i was getting into something that
i had not
uh
really understood
and then after that it was just a
constant you know you have to learn
about the loneliness there and the
poverty there i remember sam houston
johnson and his brother
telling me how he and lyndon used to sit
one part of the johnson rancher butted a
road one corner and they'd sit on the
fence there at that corner all day
hoping for one person to drive by so
they'd have somebody new
to talk to
and um the deeper i got into it the more
i realized uh gee i just don't
understand this
land this culture
you know there was an old post mistress
in johnson city named stella glidden and
she used she said to me once
you know you're a city boy you don't
understand the land and unless you
understand the land you're never going
to understand lyndon johnson and i
remember i thought oh baloney this
sounds like a grade b western or
something
but
i came to realize that she was really
telling me something
that it was the struggle to survive in a
land where survival was so hard that did
shape a lot of
johnson's characteristics so we moved
down there and for large parts of three
years i don't know how many seven eight
months a year we lived in houses on the
edge of the hill country so that i could
really
sort of immerse myself
in that land
i want to read an associated press story
a quote
because i don't want to put words in
people's mouths
because i want to go back to the london
johnson library and ask you some
questions about it former johnson aide
jack valletti has accused carroll of
being passionately met on destroying the
late president's reputation bob hardesty
a johnson speechwriter who helped him
write his memoirs called carol's
biography dishonest quote i don't think
it pretends to be fair i think it is the
work of a man with a burning unnatural
hatred for his subject hardest he said
let me let you answer those charges and
then i want to go back to the library
well i
did i don't think there's any truth in
them at all
i think i let the facts speak for
themselves i'm taking people through
lyndon johnson's life
as he lived it chronologically nobody
disputes that these are the things that
he did nobody has challenged really
anything that i know of that i that i
know i don't know of anybody
successfully challenging everything as
for disliking him that's not really true
the johnson loyalists really dislike as
you can tell
even hate
my books
that however does not mean that i
dislike lyndon johnson
i think that
the story of his life
to me is a very sad
and poignant story
it's not a question of liking and
disliking
i'm trying to understand
and make people understand more than
that i'm trying to make people
understand
i'm trying to learn how the political
power worked as he used it
and i'm trying to portray that now
that's a very unpleasant in some in this
volume it's a very unpleasant story
but that doesn't mean it didn't happen
that doesn't mean that my portraying it
means i dislike one to do
back to the library did you notice a
change in the way people treated you at
the library as they
gathered you were going to be critical
and the first volume was not uncritical
no right no but
but there were more bright sides because
see in the period of time
covered by the first volume he is doing
things that we see
things that are going to emerge in his
presidency for example we see his
compassion
for the mexican-american kids when he
was a school teacher he toured
mexican-american children down in
catoola
and i think i say in that book that no
teacher had ever cared if they learned
or not this teacher cared you know he
worked with them ceaselessly beyond you
know anything that was expected of him
of course we're going to see that in the
civil rights legislation
when he's majority leader and president
and we see in him helping his
constituents such as with rural
electrification this great gift that
lyndon johnson had for mobilizing the
powers of government
to help the dispossessed
but um
in this
i forget what you you know
if the people at the library start
treating it differently no well the
library you know reminds me very much of
the rep the situation of reporters
during the vietnam war
the people that i work with at the
library are the archivists the
they're historians professional
historians who i think chose mostly to
go into archival work instead of
teaching you know at universities
and they're very anxious
i think to see the truth come out
they're very helpful
however the hierarchy of the library um
liz carpenter warcross now people
remember from the johnson years uh
of course disliked my books just as much
as the quotes that you wrote
do you see them
doing anything to prevent you from
getting the information no
who owns the library
well the library is part of the national
archives all presidential libraries are
part of the national archives and so you
have a right to
anything you want in the course of your
research well
no it's more complicated than that
because johnson's papers were given to
the uh
federal government
under a deed of gift which was later
incorporated in a will and that
deed of gift gives the library broad
discretion
as to uh what they can close you know
anything that would harass or embarrass
someone then they remove the document
and replace it with a pink slip
and quite often as you're going through
these papers
as you're going toward it you know
you're turning every page going through
the letters of the memos as you're
heading towards the crucial moment you
see a little line of pink slip sticking
out and it's often a crucial document so
what you really just try to do
is keep going and looking in other boxes
and all you know and trying to find out
as much as you can
did you have the experience as you were
going through the files of when you
found something you knew was really
special
did did you feel any sensation at all
yeah with lyndon johnson
the sensation is quite often one of real
depression because uh
an example of that which was very
striking to me
was in the learning how he betrayed sam
rayburn you know uh in the first volume
we really see how rayburn loved lyndon
johnson uh we can call it a father-son
relationship as a cliche but
rayburn was his great patron johnson
came to washington he was the assistant
age 23 24 he's an assistant to another
congressman
and rayburn is then the mighty majority
leader
grim fierce visage man that everyone was
afraid to approach with immense power
he was a very lonely man and uh he was
lonely because he had no family no wife
no children he once wrote to his sister
god what i would give for a towel-headed
boy to take fishing but he didn't have
one when lyndon and lady bird came to
washington
uh
lyndon's father had known sam rayburn
and mr sam as they called him used to
come and spend sundays you know have
sunday breakfast and then stay around
johnson's little apartment
and he was very fond of both linden and
ladybird
once when johnson was still a young
assistant he got pneumonia which of
course was very serious back in those
days
mrs johnson was back in texas on a
vacation and rayburn sat next to
johnson's bed all night in the hospital
in a straight-backed wooden chair
he was so afraid was a chain smoke he
smoked all night but he was so afraid of
making a movement and disturbingly
that he didn't brush want to get up and
brush the ashes away so when lyndon
johnson woke up in the morning sam
rayburn was sitting there with his
lapels covered with this cigarette ash
as soon as he saw that lyndon johnson
was awake
johnson recalled rayburn leaned over him
and said lyndon don't worry about
anything if you need anything call on me
and shortly johnson did call on rayburn
rayburn got his career started
and um
now it's 1939.
john against garner and roosevelt have
split garner was always roosevelt's man
in texas someone's going to be
roosevelt's man in texas the dispenser
of the new deal power and patronage in
texas rayburn was a majority leader
still or unless he's become a speaker i
can't remember today
is the logical choice but johnson wants
that jaw
and to get it he persuades roosevelt
that ray falsely that rayburn is his
enemy
and i couldn't understand what happened
here you know
and i'm going through these boxes in the
johnson and i've interviewed some people
who were involved and i'm trying the
piece together from the interviews and
the papers what's happening and there's
never one piece of paper there's no you
know there's never one
document at least i never seem to find
one it's always a series of telegrams
and memos and you can see the picture
building up
and the picture
i mean
it was so
it was depressing to me i mean i
remember uh to be honest with you that
my thought was
oh god i hope
this doesn't mean what i think it does
i and i got up i remember and actually
left the library and walked around
outside i didn't want to go through the
rest of the stack of papers
but of course i did
and when you went through it the
evidence was incontrovertible you could
see just what lyndon johnson did so
quite often with johnson the reaction is
depressing now the other side of the
reaction is thrilling see with johnson
there's always two sides a bright side
and a dark side because in that library
are the letters from these farm women
whose lives he transformed by bringing
them electricity i mean
uh they were living without electricity
on a farm where you have to haul up
every bucket of water you know yourself
from it from a well which in the hill
country was about 75 feet deep
really made slaves out of women and
they didn't have electric washing
machines or anything
his fight to bring electricity there
which seemed impossible because it was
no
source of hydroelectric power for
miles hundreds of miles and some for
some places
was really a noble example of the use of
the powers of government to help people
to do something they couldn't do
themselves no matter how ingenious or
determined they were they were never
going to get electricity
so johnson you know did this and you can
see these letters you know thank you for
bringing the lights you know that's
that's a phrase that was used so sitting
in that library you have is a very
emotional experience sometimes of course
it's also weeks and weeks of utter
boredom you know where you keep going
through boxes and there's really nothing
that you
how many hours a day would you work in
the library well i always work it's only
open nine to five i'm never tired at
five o'clock i'm always working up to
the last you know
minute that they allow me to work in now
are you going to go back after this
volume and continue to do work in the
library sure have you been back since
people have read this book well no it
just came out last week
and you haven't been down there no since
then
um
will you talk about
you have a chapter in this book devoted
to
his
wife
and someone who is still alive uh lady
bird johnson here's a photograph do you
have to remember what year this photo
was taken 1948
and what was he doing in this year
he was running for senate against the
man on the other side of the page the
man with the pipe coach stevenson who at
that time was
well he was the former governor of texas
he was running for john against johnson
for the senate and the outcome of this
election
johnson won by 87 votes out of about a
million votes that were cast and one of
the points you make in this book is that
he stole the election the election was
stolen and how do you prove that
well i prove it
it's not it's not actually that hard to
prove just that nobody apparently
uh did it there was more than
a thousand pages of court transcripts
see hearings were held at this at the
time
and more than a thousand pages of
testimony were taken in which all the
witnesses are testifying the same way
except for one
that man was that one is a man named
louis salas who was the election judge
in the crucial precinct box 13 and jim
wells county now he testified to the
opposite of all the other people
i found mr salas in houston in 1986
he then
quite old but clear of mine and i asked
him about the discrepancy between his
testimony and everybody else's
and he said well that's simple robert i
lied under oath
and he then uh
told me and took me in great detail
through the story of what happened in
box 13
and this time his story simply
corroborated what everybody else uh had
said in this photograph uh bob carroll
uh louis salas is over here on the
it's not that we can see him yet over
here on the
no down
the far as you're looking at the screen
the far right
no on the man to the bottom
is louis salas oh okay right there as
you can see uh louis salas there is this
huge gun-toting
burley enforcer for george parr the
dooku duval when i went to see him i
guess i had this mental image of that's
what he looked like but of course he was
84 years old the man who opened the door
for me was a stooped
gentle
rather frail old man and golder and
glasses i want to get back to mrs
johnson but i want to ask you a quick
question have you ever met lyndon
johnson
i don't think i i once covered i was
just starting out as a reporter
in 1964 i was a substitute for the
reporters covering the johnson goldwater
campaign
people keep asking me that i had a
couple of days maybe four or five days
covering johnson but i was never you
know close to him i was never
a pool reporter or on the plane i saw
him from you know as a reporter when did
he die
in 1973
of uh
heart attack yes
mrs johnson you have a chapter let me
just ask you
first why did you devote a chapter
called ladybird
well
i think that the story of ladybird
johnson's transformation which in this
book means of ascent is what late the
ladybird chapter is about is one of the
most
wonderful stories that i ever heard you
know she was so shy
as a girl
she had this really painful public
shyness where she couldn't bear to speak
in public when she was in high school
she told me she prayed that if she
finished first the second in the class
and would have to give a speech as
valedictorian a salutatorian at her
graduation she prayed that she would get
smallpox and i wrote she would rather
risk the scars than speak in public now
she marries lyndon johnson she of course
cannot campaign for him make speeches
for him
more than that she doesn't participate
in the political part of his life at all
and i asked her why not and she said
well i didn't want to be part of
absolutely everything now suddenly in
means of ascent he goes off to navy
service on the west coast and in one
instance it seems like he has to say to
her now you have to run the office for
me and she has to go in having done
nothing like this and be in effect the
congressman for the 10th district of
texas and she told me about this and i
talked to the secretaries who worked in
the office with her
and to me
i mean her story of finding the courage
to make herself do things that she could
never bear to do i mean one of her
secretaries told me how mrs johnson
would sit in her husband's big chair
behind this big desk and her hand would
be reached out for the telephone but she
couldn't bear to make the course she'd
have to call a cabinet official or some
high government official
and she couldn't bear to make it but i
wrote but she always made the call i
mean she told me about the day that i
had a call that formidable mr icke who
of course was harold dickey's the
secretary of the interior the old
curmudgeon she not only had to call him
she had to go to see him and persuade
him to revoke an order
that adversely affected the 10th
district and she did
and he revoked it
and
her story of and just of how she became
turned herself
into the lady bird johnson that we know
today with her poise and graciousness
and dignity which to me it's really i
just said i'm going to tell this story
in full you did 10 interviews with her
yes where
well they would either be in the library
or once or twice they were out at her
ranch she has an office on the line
and when you interviewed someone and by
the way how many interviews did you do
for this book well
i never counted it's obviously many
hundreds did you tape record them no i
don't take record interview
long hand or short hand i i take i have
my own short hand if it's necessary to
get a paragraph or two every word i can
do that how come no tape recorder
i feel that it intimidates people i
intimidates may be the wrong word but i
feel that
i'm trying to get the truth you know to
find out what really happened
and i think that i'm dealing with some
very smart and weary men
smartest and weariest
i don't think men like that forget for
an instant that there's a tape recorder
running and whether or not that they do
i don't want any barrier between uh
their recollections and and and the
facts and i feel like there is one i
read somewhere where you wrote a million
words for this book before the editor
got to it that was for the first book
the power broker yes the original
manuscript not a rough draft the
polished manuscript was a million fifty
thousand words but we couldn't fit it
all in one book so we had to cut it down
to seven hundred thousand words and how
many words are in this book
i never
kind of it's about 500 pages i guess
it's about
250 000. i never count let me read just
a little bit this is almost the last
thing you say in this entire book on
page 425.
although from the first i made it clear
to mrs johnson that i would conduct my
own independent research into anything i
was told by anyone
for some time she very helpfully advised
members of the semi-official johnson
circle in texas that she would have no
objection if they talk with me
last sentence of your book
at a certain point however sometime
after the interviews with mrs johnson
had been completed that cooperation
abruptly and totally ceased yeah why
i don't know you have no idea well i
could speculate but it wouldn't be based
on any knowledge what year was this
always before anything was published uh
many years ago
i mean before the first volume was
published or any excerpts
and
the inner circle would not talk to you
from that day forward
well
no it's not true that no members of the
inner circle wouldn't talk to me most of
them have taught them
i don't know i don't know what you're
really asking well my point is that
undoubtedly you put this in here for a
reason
no i put it in there it's actually not
part of the book it's a part of the note
on sources
which i try to explain where i got you
know the various pieces of information
and therefore when you know i thought
people would want to know where because
a lot of the there are a lot of quotes
from mrs johnson in the book because a
lot of it came from mrs johnson
particularly you know so i thought
people would like to know
uh how i
how how that those interviews went
that's what that's why i explained well
on the other side of this is that john
connolly supposedly wouldn't talk to you
for a long time read the first volume
and then what he did
then he called me well i i have to you
know he called me and said very
flattering things about the first volume
and said that he therefore didn't want
me to do the second volume without him
and would i come down and see him and i
said yes and he said the only place we
can get away from everybody else is at
my ranch so i went down to his ranch and
spent whatever three or four days there
now however
for whatever reason i won't speculate mr
connolly uh
says very differently
so um i mean about about my work about
your work right of course in this book
he is a source you know in particular in
this 48 campaign he was one of
johnson's bright young men really the
leader of the bright young men in this
48 campaign
and he talked to me quite frankly about
it and he would not agree at all with my
conclusions but i'm sure that he
wouldn't disagree
with any that would say that i misquoted
him or anything like that do you think
that
because
mr johnson put out the word to all these
people and and they wouldn't talk to
anymore and if you don't want to
speculate the fact that they wouldn't
talk to you anymore did that hurt your
book well no because um
i would i refer to uh
to there
it's not that they wouldn't tour i mean
like for this book the people who were
closest in this period just to stay on
this because it gets too confusing
otherwise
uh who were closest to lyndon johnson
with john connolly walter jenkins
horace busby warren woodward
george brown of brown and root edward a
claw perhaps 20 of them i named them
without exception 100 percent all talk
to me and talk to me as much as i wanted
so
that's not really accurate there are
members of the johnson circle
who i wouldn't
when actually just a couple who wouldn't
talk to me
and i'm sure i'll find more but the fact
is that each time one of these excerpts
ran in the new yorker i couldn't keep up
with the people telephoning or sending
me letters or contacting me through an
intermediary to really say why haven't
you talked to me yes usually it was
because i'm not up to i'm not up to them
yet
well one other thing on the on the
source thing that the greatest single
lost in my research in my opinion came
with the death of abe fortis yes why
well a you know in this abe for this
first place
was very close to lyndon johnson at
crucial moments in his life
now in this volume would be much poorer
johnson saved the senate election
because of a legal maneuver
by abe forders fordus explained it to me
and i think the book is much richer for
that
i think
he died right between two interviews i
had had an interview with him and he i
asked him a question he said oh that's
an important question we'll talk about
it whenever in a week or whatever and we
made a date
then i picked up the new york times one
morning and abe fortis had died very
young of a heart attack that was i can't
ever
i mean that will hurt my work
in my opinion all the way through
is there a difference between
your work as a
journalist and the
professorial academician profes uh
historian type i mean you approach the
these volumes differently and i know
there's always an argument about what is
history
well i think that um
there are a number of you know things
that are important to me
one is the level of the writing
the thing that always mattered to me
was that my books endure
and i have a theory about history see i
don't regret my books as biographies so
much as i do with history so i call them
the years of lyndon johnson
and
i feel that in order to endure a work of
history has to be written the prose has
to be at the same level as a novel that
will endure
and i don't think there's enough
emphasis
in the writing
of a lot of history
on the fact that this is a book if the
history is thrilling if the events are
thrilling
you're not being true to history
if you make it boring
if you concentrate just on the facts and
don't give a sense of place sense of the
people involved i think narrative is
important and empathy is important
you went to school at princeton yes
you worked for how many years at newsday
on long island i think six years
you've done
a total of three books now yes
and you've got two volumes of this to go
yes
one of the things in the back
that also was
caught my attention was
the two pages you wrote about your wife
you called her your quiet idealist
explain
why you called her your quiet idealist
but what how important was she to this
whole process oh she's an integral part
of the process she's the whole staff you
know most
most
major biographies presidential
biographies if you look in the
acknowledgments in fact it's a whole
list of researchers and archivists i
could never trust other people to look
at papers because you know only i know
but einer knows she's she einer is a
great historian in her own right she's a
medieval historian in fact she's writing
a book of her own
when i was writing the power broker
there was a time i was hurt
i couldn't get out of bed for a long
time
and
i had a t china had a yanker away from
the middle ages she was doing her
phd thesis on education and under
charlemagne
and i had to yank her away from that and
send her out to to really
do investigative reporting work for me
and ever since then we've worked
together and um
she's a wonderful historian
and i guess i call her uh
my beloved idealist because she's
beloved to me and she's an idealist i
said quiet idealist but beloved idea
listen but you did say anna caro is
quiet and calm and wise
but the last line i don't know what i'm
going to do without her help yes which
now she's writing her own book
what's that on it's a
guy a travel history of france through
the eyes of a historian so each time you
go to a castle or a chateau you're not
just looking at a building you know all
these things that happened there in
history wonderful story
you write about her
let's see if i can find it in pursuing
that she crisscrossed the united states
spending weeks for example going through
papers of former senator richard russell
yeah in a library in athens georgia
those of willis robertson
who is the father of pat robertson in a
library in williamsburg virginia and
those are presidents roosevelt and
truman and hyde park and independence
missouri
uh why all those libraries and what did
you find there that you hadn't already
oh well you can never do you know you
can never do uh just a a a work of
history just from the one source now
when she was in the richard russell
library because i'm going in great
detail into johnson as majority leader
richard bravoid russell of georgia
was the great southern patriarch and
leader you know of the southerners in
the senate and i wanted to know all
about his relations with lyndon johnson
so einer went down to the russell
library uh in the truman library same
thing you know you try to go through
we've gone through the papers
of many
senators of that period you know in
their own earl clemens papers for
example
are in lexington kentucky
and tom clark's papers are out in the
truman library roosevelt library you
know we've spent between the two of us
really endless months in different
libraries it's not just the johnson
library that you do the work
do you think that
london johnson would be as anxious as he
was to have a library if he knew that
a lot of the material that is in that
library would end up in a book like this
what do you think he would react what
would he be his reaction to this book
oh i i you know lyndon johnson as we saw
as president did not take kindly
to criticism
however when he reads all four books
i think that
when he sees the life as a whole
he's likely to feel
that i gave him both in the
bright sense as well as the dark sense
his place in history you know
i wrote in
the introduction to this book
that it was abraham lincoln who struck
the chains from black americans but it
was lyndon johnson who took them by the
hand led them into the voting booth drew
democracy's curtain behind them and made
them once and for all and forever be
part of american political life that's
coming it's not in this volume but it's
coming
by the way do you after going through
all this do you think the ends justify
the means
i i can't answer that question i like
that it's too complicated what i will
say is that this volume means of ascent
raises the great question
of the connection between means and ends
because many of the ends of lyndon
johnson's life were noble heroic
advances i mean we wouldn't have a lot
of the civil rights legislation we have
today if lyndon johnson hadn't pushed it
through
but he wouldn't have been in position
to however that's not to say his
presidency was a triumphant presidency
because it divided the country it caused
the credibility gap it had a lot of dark
sides but whatever the ends are
good and bad they wouldn't be possible
if it wasn't for the means
by which she got to a position to have
those ends which are in this fine
bottomless capacity for deceit deception
and betrayal yes
was he a dishonest man knowingly
well i don't know what knowingly means
you think he did these things and he
knew that he was doing
i think he was a man who had to win
i see in this
i think we all see in this volume in
this election
a man who had to win
he uh you know he had kidney stones
during this campaign
it was his last chance
kidney stones are a particularly
agonizing pain and this was a terrible
attack and his fever was 105 degrees and
the doctors told him you know you must
get to a hospital you're risking the
loss of a kidney function in fact if it
goes on you're risking the loss of your
life he wouldn't stop campaigning he was
laying he was driving back and forth
across texas lying in the back of the
car between stops gagging and wretching
perspiration pouring off him but every
time they pulled into a town he'd get on
a clean shirt big smile and he
bound out he'd shake every hand and give
the speech
when you use the word knowingly or
unknowingly i almost think it's deeper
than that with lyndon johnson he simply
had to win
before you leave the kidney stone story
tell the
tell the little bit on the train well
the little bit on the train was told to
me
by warren woodward who was a young aide
of lyndon johnson
uh he's coming back from this trip to
the panhandle
he has to come back to dallas because
secretary of the air force stewart
symington is flying to dallas to let
johnson announce with him a period of
press conference and announce with him
that the air force base is going to stay
open
on the plan on the train coming back you
see with kidney stones and 105 degree
fever you have alternately
terrible chills and terrible fever so
johnson was in a pullman birth woodward
was across the aisle johnson would
really scream woody woody i'm burning up
i'm burning up get open the window so
woodward would lean across the uh him
and with the porter they they tugged the
ends of the wind get the window
five minutes later johnson said i'm
freezing i'm freezing and
woodward and the porter would get all
the blankets and pile them on then it'll
be freeze uh heat again they raised the
window and finally johnson was so cold
he said woody get into bed with me hold
me you know for body warmth and
woodward did and johnson was just
shaking he was so uh
racked with fever and chills the
fantastic thing about this was that the
next day
now woodward is a young man he doesn't
know what to do simonton is coming up to
johnson's hotel room
woodward just can't get johnson to stop
he feels johnson may die
so he before woodward johnson's in the
bedroom late rest
when woodward locks at the door uh when
charmington knocks at the door woodward
goes and whispers to him how sick
johnson
symington would never have known if
wouldn't woodward hadn't told him the
door to the bedroom opens there's lyndon
johnson
big smile
ready to talk about the air force base
because he didn't want anything to
interfere with the campaign i call that
chapter will
i think it's a triumph
of the will uh
knowingly and unknowingly i don't think
even goes deep enough with lyndon
johnson in the ladybird chapter you talk
about his mistress yeah did she know
about his mistress i don't know did you
ask her about his mistress no i didn't
why not
i couldn't bear to
why
well i think i just said as a matter of
fact
was that the only question you couldn't
ask her yes
how did you find out and how did you
verify the fact that he did it oh well
actually her sister and her best friend
approached me
and
said we've read the power broker you
seem to find out everything about your
subject and we know you're going to find
out about alice
and we don't want alice portrayed as son
bimbo she was a quite unusual woman and
she was very important in lyndon
johnson's life
and she was
and i learned about her from the sister
from the best friend and from i think
of four or five other sources who were
named in the book and of course in the
second volume we even quote a letter
during the war when he was out on the
coast
she visits him
and later you know writes jokingly to a
friend who
gave me the letter years later you know
when he's president says that's jokingly
she says let's collaborate on a
biography on lyndon i can write the
chapter on his war service in hollywood
where the hollywood photographers were
trying to teach him which is the best
side of his face so there is no lack of
you know ever i mean it was not it was
not a short affair
it was very important in his life
i felt you had to write about it
for two reasons
number one she was very important in his
life when he came to washington he was a
young awkward gorky congressman he
didn't know how to dress you know he had
long arms the wrist stuck out of his
shirt
and
she taught him how to dress she had a
very elegant salon she had a wonderful
estate
in the virginia hunt country
and
she also was very astute politically
and there was a time in johnson's early
career where he was really
had a problem with this chief financial
backer herman brown of brown and ruth
and brown was a man that nobody crossed
and johnson and him were on a collision
course and it was alice glass
who devised the compromise
give herman the dam and let linden have
the land which really saved his career
in that sense
did you write uh i can't remember the
details that uh
lady bird johnson and
former president johnson would spend
time at his mistresses
yes they went down to well it was a
great estate in virginia
uh and they would both go down there and
on other occasions he would go down and
leave lady bird at home so you don't
know whether or not she knew or not no i
do not
this is really off the subject but
warren g harding
fdr
john f kennedy lyndon johnson
must be leaving some general eisenhower
all rumored and some there was evidence
had mistresses what is it about
presidents
and mistresses poor men
i i don't know but
in johnson's life
uh alice glass played a role you see his
entire character emerged in some ways in
his dealings you know with alice glass
and uh when he goes to the pacific he
can't decide whether to file for the
senator to file for congress and it's
her opinion he wants
for years
i've heard a rumor around this town and
i don't think it's in the book here but
i want to ask you about whether or not
you ever found it
there in communication circles they were
all they always used to say that
there was one television station
in austin texas for a long time ktbc i
know you write about the radio station
uh that lyndon johnson used to call fcc
commissioners and say if you keep that
one station there
and not allow any other zen i'll put you
back on the commission did you ever find
any evidence that he used
the commission and the appointment
process when he was president
to keep control
and the value in his television station
well i'm not up to that yet and so i
can't answer when you say you're not up
to that would that be something you
write in another volume yes i'm happy to
talk about anything i've written but not
about stuff that i haven't read and i
haven't i haven't finished my research
on the presidency when is your next
volume doing
well i'm writing it now
i finished a lot of the research on it
and i hope that this won't take so long
i'm really hoping that it'll be out in
two or three years does this get any
harder for you the more you do this or
is it easier well it's sort of
fascinating to be honest with you
because now the focus shifts from texas
i loved learning about texas i miss
stuck i mean i miss it already
but washington
is fascinating too
during this last i well before i
finished the last stage of writing i
used to sit in the senate gallery all
day you know we'll walk around the cloak
rooms and the hideaways just trying to
get a sense of the senate you know and i
felt like
they're staging this show the senators
show that they're staging for me i love
it
to be honest have you noticed people
treating you differently the more
they read your books the more visible
you become
well
yes and i i you're asking
i do people recognize you on the street
and yes uh
it doesn't happen to be something that
i'm really in love with
do you find people who don't agree with
you becoming
um i really had to put this question
do you find yourself being confronted
from time to time by people who don't
like what you're writing well you know
that goes through stages when the first
volume came out and when the power
broker came out there's this wave of
controversy at the beginning but with my
first two books i learned
that after a very short time it all
fades away and blurs in your mind you
can't remember the reviews bad or good
you can't remember whether you published
it took enough ads and i you know the
only thing that's left is the book
and it seemed to me that in both cases
my first two books once people settled
down to read
what i really wrote
that faded away
and they just became accepted
so that right now we're in the first
week after publication or in whatever
you want we're monthly after publication
um
and i hope this will be accepted uh
in the spirit that i wrote
and in this next volume you're not going
to have the help of your wife
[Laughter]
is that going to make it is that going
to change the nature you have the same
editor
yes i i hope to always have the same
editor
robert gottlieb was the editor that he
went from konaf to the new yorker but he
edited this book just like he did the
others and i hope to have the
same publishing house and i hope that
ifina finishes her book
that she'll find time to help me on the
next one too because as i wrote in the
end of this book i don't know what i'll
do without
the name of the book is the years of
lyndon johnson
means of ascent
written by robert a carrow our guest for
the last hour thank you for joining us
[Music]
book notes airs every sunday at 8 p.m
eastern time and again at 11 p.m eastern
time
morley safer co-editor of 60 minutes
joins us next week to discuss his book
flashbacks on returning to vietnam
that's next sunday here on c-span
in about half an hour from now we will
continue our look at the life of lyndon
johnson with the national press
foundation program with journalists who
knew him that's in search of lbj coming
up at 9 40 p.m eastern time but now stay
with us for prime minister's question
time in britain's house of commons is
next
[Music]
in the form of labor